au revoir les enfants
patron je descends vie de voir justin et
b2 petit jeune qui monte seul le jury
pourtant peu pauvre homme pour notre
nounours est très impatient ce soir car
il veut savoir le temps qu'il fera
demain vous allez voir que grâce à notre
petite grenouille ont pu l'apprendre
mais on peut aussi se tromper ça arrive
parce que j'ai sommeil pimprenelle moi
aussi nicolas beau soir les enfants aux
sports christine bossard
comment vous avez déjà sauveur pourquoi
tu nous as pratique les grenouilles
saint jean toute la nuit
elle a chanté toute la nuit et on n'a
pas pu dormir je la chantais froha tu
parles tu crois quoi croquera
trois croix crocro as tu sûr merveilleux
et elles montaient ou descendaient son
échelle elle manque inquiet du sort
d'une heure mais pourquoi n 1 mes
enfants pour les grenouilles croise et
grains à leur échelle ça veut dire que
le lendemain il fera beau c'est comme ça
qu'on fait les prévisions
météorologiques
et bien moi je les plains ceux qui font
ça et doivent pas d'or bien souvent du
daim et humain quand ils descendent un
échelle ça veut dire qu'il va pleuvoir
non pas moi les grenouilles au quoi
nourrir quelques essences en échelle
c'est vrai mon dieu il va pleuvoir mais
non quoi elle remonte sommet chez elle
et sur les deuxièmes parrot c'est bien
juste une
pourquoi c'est bien 'cela signifie
légère hausse de la température
elle est au milieu de l'échelle joe
justin en variable sur la moitié du biz
elle redescend d'une marche
quelques ondées sont les petits revenus
oh la la
quel changement de temps les enfants qui
comprend plus rien c'est sans doute le
scirocco ce local avec pour une matinale
ça à tous je suis bon c'est ça
temps variable très vague voyez comme
c'est facile de faire des prévisions
météorologiques
tétreault l'album n'est justin ne chante
pas trop cette nuit
oh
[Musique]
et tous
demain on fera encore des prévisions
météo
oh bien sûr j'ai encore des tas de
choses à vous apprendre c'est là
j'éteins la lune ne nie pas les grenats
noces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un bon conseil ne prenez pas trop au
sérieux
les prévisions de nounours temps
variable patron au puzzle
merci nounours et demain variable patron
très variable et bien en route nounours
bonne nuit les petits faites de beaux
[Musique]
coût
mon
[Musique]